for us to survive for us to thrive parts
of our Lives just have to be connected
and on a really authentic level
unique and that's because my guest is
unique his name is John Pearson and John
has the very interesting distinction of
being the original male supermodel for
me I always knew that if you had a good
time and you really engaged with
somebody if you do that with genuine
Integrity that transmits to the person
who's looking at that picture he's a guy
who pioneered the male modeling
profession he was the most sought after
male model throughout the 90s he was
also the male face of George Michael's
iconic Freedom music video which was
directed by a young David Fincher and
actually I went into George's trailer to
rehearse the song and he actually forgot
the words
and I did the orange in one meal and
chucked him it landed perfectly all in
one so I knew I was on the right track
yeah but it's important that you guys
know that John is a friend he's a kind
beautiful and wise soul and he's here
today not so much because of his past
although that is of course fascinating
he's lived a very unique life and we do
go into it but really more because of
how he lives today and I think if it's a
negative habit I think you have to
challenge that at some point because
otherwise you're going to be in the same
ruts over and over and over again and I
just really wanted to
I wanted to have a bit of control over
my life in this conversation we
discussed mental health and modeling
healthy masculinity which are the themes
that underscore John's very cool
lifestyle and self-improvement digital
magazine which is called Mr feel good no
matter how tired I am no matter how warm
out I am I want to be present you know I
want to be real John is a very special
guy he's really one of my absolute
favorite people and I'm really excited
to introduce you to him so let's do that
right now this is me
John Pearson enjoy
I'm delighted to have you here uh you
know it's interesting because we've been
friends for a couple years and I know
you but I don't know you super well and
it's been really fun kind of doing uh
internet excavation of your life you've
been incredibly interesting life and the
first thing I want to explore with you
is like my the sense that I had kind of
learning more and more about
um your journey
uh is this idea that if I had
experienced 1 100th of what you were
exposed to as a young person in your 20s
in New York in London Tokyo these
Adventures that you've had I I would
most certainly be dead like how are you
such a well-adjusted grounded you know
gentle soul after you know all the
things that you you know the the kind of
uh
you know worlds that you've navigated
oh wow that's a big one and thank you
for that
um I think it was just very important
for me from the start to
sort of establish
some sort of control or equilibrium
about what I was navigating as a young
man going into this world going into
this business going into this thing that
was so in contrast to where I came from
and it just as a yorkshireman from North
England you know you always used to hear
don't ever change so there was a real
grounding roots in me anyway growing up
where I wanted to just I kind of
love the whole idea of Adventure in life
and I was really from the age of four
probably but definitely from the age of
11 I was just really wanting to see
everything and not be put in a box and
explore and be excited about life and it
always came back to okay I can see all
the chaos around me and I can dance
within the chaos but I have to stay
grounded and rooted and it wasn't
something that was
you know that I had some magic pill for
it took work and it took energy and it
took Focus to sort of
um determine what kept me grounded and
at times you know it was pretty a major
during the 80s and the 90s when I'm
traveling and working non-stop twice to
Europe in a week working both times and
that went on for years just to keep your
sort of keep your head right you know
yeah I I it sounds as if there was some
sort of uh self-defense mechanism inside
of you that put up some guard rails
because I I imagine that you've
seen quite a bit of Carnage I mean that
period in the 80s and you know late 80s
New York City uh you know the worlds
that you were in I mean there's got to
be like a lot of you know dead friends
in your wake as a result of kind of
lifestyle that was happening yeah yeah
yeah yeah I have
um it was incredible it was incredible
it was incredible and at times
it was too much because at times the
traveling and being the center of
attention and turning up and playing the
clown in a way because I always felt
part of my job description was to not be
afraid to be the fool so I could ex so I
could be light so I can be present so
that I could serve the people around me
and um but there were times when yeah it
was it was pretty mental you know is it
the traveling around the world they're
going out then doing crew dinners every
night and always been on always been on
I think when I was in my mid-20s I just
got to this point where I just I didn't
want anyone to touch me to come near me
I had multiple bookings for the next six
months and I said to my agent months to
his chagran you know I I I I I can't do
this anymore so I went off to Jamaica on
my own never been to Jamaica and spent a
week there just sort of writing and
meditating and being clear and trying to
find peace and then it actually when I
did that when I came back that was the
first time that I feel I'd really
honored myself and given myself the time
and that just shifted something in me
and I thought oh this I can I can have
control of myself I can sort of figure
these things out and navigate and know
who I am you know I mean it's an ongoing
project even at this age but yeah I mean
in 2022 to do that it would be something
that would be celebrated but you know
back then probably you were told like
you're crazy or why are you doing that
or you need to do as you're told and
show up or I was never told you need to
do as you're told no way because you
hear these stories about the modeling
world and you're a piece of meat and you
show up here and you hit your marks and
you you know put on the put on the
whatever they want you to do but it
sounds like your experience was more
collaborative and healthy it was and I
think if you know if you and I don't
mean to sound self-righteous because I
was very wobbly at times but I think
if you enter a room and you go into a
place knowing who you are people pick up
on that and if you want to be abused
it can happen but for me I I never you
know I never
I don't think I I
fought at times with the idea of being a
male model because I'm a northerner you
know and I'm from a you know it is a
weird it's a weird thing I mean it's a
thing like yeah like uh you know you're
you're such a recognizable face people
that don't follow that world at all
probably see you and think oh I know
that guy or maybe I met him or I know
him from somewhere I mean there's no
magazine that you haven't been in so at
some point it gets imprinted on the
unconscious mind but they don't know you
they may not know your name and that has
to be kind of disorienting for you as
well right
no no you're like on the wrong track no
no I want I want to answer your
questions because I you know I just
abuse me all of these ideas I I look at
myself you know what I've done and it's
it's not very interesting to me what I'm
doing now is really interesting we're
going to get to that no I know
um but no I mean
I'm trying to think you know I saw a lot
of Carnage I saw a lot of
I saw a lot of behavior that wasn't
great but I always naturally was
empathetic and I was always I was sort
of brought up to stand up for people and
stand up for myself so I never really
was chasing conflict but I wanted to
just make the day which I do to this day
the best day it could be and and I was
working too hard
and yeah I had fun and you know all my
friends were the DJs in New York so I
come back to New York I always had the
best place to go to I was in the DJ
booth I saw all that I enjoyed all that
but I also had to get up the next day
and I've always had this sense of
responsibility and a work ethic because
I'm A working class boy from Yorkshire
to get there and do the best I can in
the day with what I've got so there was
always a really grown-up kind of stoic
get to it you know have a good attitude
and that's where you'll succeed and I
was really I was really focused about
having an interesting life that's what
it's been but as far as your question
you know being just a pretty face and
all those things and feeling you know
I don't know I didn't go to a great
University or anything like that I
didn't have that education I educated
myself reading on books going across the
Atlantic and around the world for 25
years you know that that I kind of
wrestled with that at times during my
20s because I was trying to figure out
what I really wanted to do what my
purpose in life was and then
but I didn't I didn't I didn't you know
I I just got found peace with it
eventually and I just thought look I'm
really
I can't swear can I I can but I can but
I'm really [__] lucky unfortunate
literally what I wanted to do I was
coming home from a girlfriend's place on
two two buses on a Sunday night in rainy
Yorkshire and I saw this billboard for a
couple two guys two girls in bikinis
sort of in trunks in the Seychelles and
I thought oh I want a bit of that life
and and literally within a year it
started to happen and I never thought
it'd go to where it went but it did yeah
you know so it's pretty amazing I mean
you're in your fourth decade of doing
this thing man really come on we're the
same age
yeah but that sense of responsibility uh
that that sense of having to be a
grown-up you know came was visited upon
you early right like when your father
passed away at a young age yeah yeah I
mean my parents divorced when I was four
years old I have two older sisters and a
mum I went to live with them an hour and
a half away
and my father for the until I was 11 was
a great father and saw us every other
weekend but he passed away and and yeah
it was it was massive it was massive and
I don't think with all respect to my
family and those around me and being
English I think at that point in time
there was the sort of counseling and the
supports that a young person would have
I was literally told
bye
someone to just go to my father's grave
you know my mum asked someone a man a
supposed Mentor what you know have a
word with John and I you know little boy
in a little cap in a little suit so that
his grave and through and this guy said
oh just Chuck some dirt on there and say
don't worry Dad I've got this I'll look
after everyone really and I did you know
that's what I did and what amazing
advice I know yeah I know you know and
then I was told by one of a family
member a senior family member that I
could go to private school and I could
have a great you know education but I
was terrified to leave my mother and my
kids you know and I said I'll get
everything out of my comprehensive
school that I can get out of a private
school and I did but I was you know it
was just it was there wasn't that
support system there wasn't that
understanding of that no no no healthy
male mentors
no so you just went and got a bunch of
jobs right yeah started at 12 in the
market selling vegetables and fruits and
was you know fantastic I'd work from 7am
till 5 30. I'd work with every kind of
person every sort of you know in the
from poor people Working Class People
rich people Posh people educated Not
educated I'd come home at night and I'd
have five bags of Old Second fruit which
I'd sell again I only made two pound
fifty a day half an hour off in the in
the at lunch time and then I went from
there into a jean store which is a
really hip jean store and was a manager
there within weeks and was the you know
the best salesman in the whole 50 out of
53 stores and so I just got busy and I
got and I just wanted to be independent
and I wanted to get out there in the
world and I just wanted to have you know
the career officer couldn't figure me
out they said we know you'd do well but
um we don't know what you'll do you
could go and work in the factory and
that was like no you know I can't work I
want to see the world I was I loved
American television shows and you know
palm trees and California and yeah so
that dream was kind of uh ruminating in
the in the back of your Consciousness
and then one day someone walks into the
denim shop right like and this kind of
changes everything yeah yeah I was I was
selling stretch jeans and I loved it and
this was the era so this must have been
like 80
we remember it well
divisions really I was having a great
time and yeah a guy came in and sort of
said hey I'd like to take pictures of
you and at first I was a bit what's this
a little bit uh
a little bit
um suspicious but then I thought let's
have a go and I was mad about sort of
James Dean and Montgomery Cliff and
American Gregory Peck and all the movies
and and as soon as I got on the set and
I took my sister with me actually
because I was a little bit nervous my
own clothes and he just started shooting
and I just felt really eat at ease and I
felt like you know I had that youthful
sort of confidence and
aspirations and I just I just I just
felt at ease you know and I thought this
is fun this is good I can you know I can
make this happen there's some joy in
here there's some energy so yeah and how
long between that experience and
everything kind of clicking into place
in New York City
um gosh I think after that
my sister sent some pictures off to this
magazine in London called look now which
was the the sort of you know the team
team bopper sort of magazine of the day
and they invited me down to London I
think I'd only been to London once
before to see a play with my school
and I went down got in a black taxi for
the first time went to North London went
in and there were two extraordinarily
beautiful French girls and I I brought
my cassette tape with me of all my music
shoved it on and uh had an amazing time
shot an editorial then I went back up to
Yorkshire that night and carried on
working and then they called me back and
said would you come and do another
magazine and another cover so I went
down did that
and I don't think I wasn't even living
in London then I moved to London when I
was 18 and again I had I wanted to be an
actor I had no idea what would happen
but the agency took me on
um I started working very quickly I was
like okay this is a bit weird I wasn't
sort of I didn't feel that I looked like
the male models that I'd seen in you
know Vogue and everything else I felt
like a bit of a scruffy outsider
um and then things started to happen and
then I went to Japan I made a bit of
money I had an extraordinary experience
in 86 and then the idea was to come to
New York on November the 4th
1986 I flew to New York with a great
buddy of mine and about two days later
it just started to happen I did the
cover of self with Uma Thurman I you
know I went in my first limousine I saw
I met Cindy Crawford for the first time
she just arrived from Chicago I couldn't
believe it yeah and it just steamrolled
and I really thought that it was just
going to be you know a couple of months
and this is fun and now wait tables and
I'll be an actor and get into the Actors
Studio and it just started and it just
was perpetual and it just you know I I
in those days as well you could book a
client and you'd have them you know
twice a year or four times a year for
six or seven years so you really became
it was before actors started going on
the front and celebrities started going
on the front of magazines so it was just
this you know exponential immediate
growth that happened and it sort of took
me by surprise but I thought right I'm
gonna make the most of this yeah I mean
it was also
like a timing thing because this was all
occurring at the very beginning of this
whole supermodel you know kind of
obsession where well such a like this
the whole supermodel thing right like
wasn't a thing until like the mid I mean
when did that start I mean you were
there right when yeah Genesis of that
yeah and it was this intersection of
like music rock and roll culture fashion
um and and the kind of glossy magazine
era I mean magazine like it's just not
what it was back then like it was a big
deal right yeah and all of that was kind
of happening you know at the same time
it was like this perfect storm and New
York seemed to be like the place where
that was occurring and then there you
were yeah how lucky am I it was great
and these these women become household
names right you know and you're right
there like I want to talk about the
George Michael video yeah that's like
crazy right like it's just so iconic all
of it yeah no it was it was you know it
was a magical moment it was as you say
like a fusion of fashion and and film
and excitement and youth and there was a
real movement and yeah yeah that great
cover I forget what year it was but it's
around 91 maybe 92 of uh Peter limbo
shot of all the girls on the cover of
Vogue and then the freedom video and I
was the guy I was one of the guys that
was sort of the prominent guy and I
almost didn't do it so it's really funny
but it was only because I knew the girls
because I won't in the Milan I thought
all right I'll do this
um but yeah it was a magical time it was
extraordinary it was vital it was
happening it was Dynamic it was a great
time to be alive in New York at that
time it really was I hadn't watched that
video in a while and I watched it last
night and I was like wow like it it does
not there's nothing about it that feels
dated or aged I mean the song is so so
good incredible and the you know the
women are just radiant in that and then
you're like you are the stand-in for
George Michael like you are his sort of
kid or you know uh super ego yeah
throughout that video it's really quite
something and I couldn't help but think
like this is part of the myth making of
of what the supermodel you know was at
that time and kind of uh
you know a way of of uh
it's sort of like this touchdown of
where the culture was because that video
was also directed by David Fincher right
one of his early things like he was just
I think he was just editing his first
alien movie okay alien movie his first
feature yeah yeah yeah so all of those
like you know culturally relevant people
in one place at one time it was George
Michael like there behind the scenes so
I should tell you I should tell you that
was a crazy week because I was literally
working in New York I flew to Stockholm
I shot in Stockholm I took a train to
Lapland I shot two nights in Lapland
during their summer so there was I was
in this hotel room with blackout blinds
and I literally still had to sleep with
my head in the bathroom at the back of
the room because it was still coming
through I left there I went to Paris I
did a night shoot for a I think it was
it wasn't Brandy because yeah it was a
brandy ad at the Garden Nord so I did a
night shoot then I flew to London at six
in the morning straight from the shooter
a car picked me up I had to learn the
song on the way to the studios
uh because you're lip syncing
and I was really sort of like I want to
learn this you know I didn't know
there'd be an also cue so I was really
Keen but it's a really easy song to get
into but there's a couple of
couple of verses that are tricky because
they're so similar
um put it on and we'll sing it now
um
and and then I got there and you know
first person I saw was Christy and that
which was great it was a delight I I
shot my days with Christy and with Linda
I mean amazing people amazing humans
incredible incredible models really and
and humans more so
um and I Met George you know and and
actually I went into Jaws George's
trailer to rehearse the song and he
actually forgot the words
so I was pleased that I'd learned them
and it just was it was a magical day it
was a magical day and I literally wore
my own clothes that I turned up in
Camilla The Stylist you know she said oh
just wear that I had long johns on I
think and wore my own clothes and and
nothing happened that day and then the
producer came over to me and said I said
oh are you free tomorrow can you shoot
tomorrow because we've got a wrap today
I said sure he said you don't mind doing
it for free I said yes I do I said I
know how much they're getting and I was
really I was really sort of I was you're
lucky it's working this is working class
though but it was that sort of principal
thing so I came back the next day and I
had an orange and I was peeling an
orange and David came over with George
and said right John hi nice to see you
you know uh what should we do he said I
like the way you're peeling your orange
I said well last night I saw this great
picture of
of Paul Newman outside the access center
sat in a doorway looking at the script
he said perfect and he built me the
frame and literally it was three takes
and we had it done uh yeah because
you're lounging yeah and and I and I did
the orange in one field and chucked it
and it landed perfectly all in one so I
knew I was on the right track yeah but
was there a sense
nobody could have known like what what a
big deal that video was going to be I
mean times were different we lived in
much more of a mono culture and MTV was
important then yeah and when videos like
this premiered it was an event right and
that video definitely struck a cultural
Accord at the time yeah I mean I I
really just thought it was another job
which sounds very sort of
um
I hope it doesn't sound arrogant but it
was like another job and I was off to
another job the next day and I didn't
realize it the the
um
the importance the the gravitas of it
until I was working about three months
later because also in those days which
which was lovely there was an
anticipation of seeing the work three
months later and it wasn't immediate and
it wasn't forgotten and then it became
so it sort of built its iconic status in
a way and you waited to see those things
and um and I was in a I was in a hotel
shooting in a bar in Miami and suddenly
the the television was on in the back it
was MTV and it came on and everyone just
started bopping and oh wow wow and I was
like okay I think I'm in this if they
haven't cut me out and the opening scene
I think is mine knows and then suddenly
it happened I thought oh that's pretty
good because you you sing the first
verse yeah you're like the first person
we see yeah I believe right yeah no for
sure yeah and then and then of course it
just became this phenomena which went on
and on and to this day and I really
didn't understand the importance of it
until later
um and uh you know I'm I when I well you
know I I just really glad to be a part
of it now did you ever cross paths with
George again after that
um I saw him once in the Ivy and he was
absolutely lovely and um and I wish I'd
seen him more he was such a talent he
was so extraordinary oh that's the other
thing when I met him for the first time
this is I think it was just bravado it's
just boys stuff I went up I said oh
hello George I know you I know all about
you because our birthdays are two days
apart but you're two years older than me
that's the first line I said to him and
he kind of looked back at me like who's
this strange person but then we just you
know we just got on really well he was
very warm he was
he was he was
he was just he was into it and he was
just right there and he really wanted to
make a statement
I feel like most people want to eat
better they want to improve their diets
absolutely have you heard of it I've
heard of it this trips up so many people
we thought hey we know a couple things
about how to do this a few so we created
this thing called the plant power meal
planner that is this beautiful offering
whereby you gain access to literally
thousands of plant-based recipes that
you can totally customize based upon
your preferences your allergies your
peccadillos it integrates with grocery
delivery so all the ingredients that you
need get shipped right to your door so
you can make the stuff that you've
pre-selected and we all could use a
little inspiration and support when
preparing meals for our families in our
busy lives so we hope you join us no
matter what your eating style is we have
our arms open wide and we've saved you a
space at our family table to join us in
eating more healthy vibrant plant-based
meals and if you're looking for the
perfect holiday gift for a loved one
right now for a limited time we're
offering twenty dollars off meal planner
gift cards through December 15th visit
meals.rich roll.com to claim the offer
again for twenty dollars off meal
planner gift cards from now until
December 15th visit meals dot
richroll.com
over the course of your career you've
worked with essentially every great
photographer what is your sense of like
what makes for a great image and how do
you think about like the myth making of
of those images because so many of the
campaigns that you've been involved with
are really about telling a story or you
know creating
um
you know a sense of of an aspirational
lifestyle right that that like inspires
people there's a dark side to it I
suppose as well but there's something
kind of really
cool from a creative perspective to work
with such amazing Image Makers yeah you
know like what makes them great like
what what is the difference between you
know somebody who is utilitarian as a
photographer and that person who just
sees something that no one else sees and
can capture that it's I mean I work with
everyone and I like you say and I've
I've worked to every level and I'm you
know I've still to this day I'm very
grateful to work at the the high level
as well and do campaigns but it's when
someone's got a signature and if
someone's got a signature of a look or
the way they are they're very set in the
way they want to produce something and
they're concentrated and the
environments around them is all on you
know
all on the same level of support then
you just know you knew that you were in
the company of people who would be doing
something would be photographing you in
a way that elevated the whole day
and you knew you were in great hands and
you learned from that and then you were
free within that to sort of create I was
always looking
to do stuff that was different because I
you know I got sick of looking at myself
and you kind of you just want to see
what can I learn here so I picked up the
the people who are really
amazing are the people that are
concentrated and they really love what
they do and they have a signature which
is which sort of
separates them from the mass and they
they are sincere with that and they
can't I just immediately think of Peter
Lindberg who is extraordinary he had
such joy and he loved what he did and he
worked hard and he put everything into
it but he ran a set that was all you
know focused on us all having a
wonderful time and also getting the
great image that would stand the test of
time and they really they do and they
will all his [__] are amazing yeah
yeah and there's a few people like that
and we had great art directors Fabian
Baron you know was extraordinary and
Trey Laird and I worked with them on
multiple campaigns and editorials and
they were characters and they really
knew what they wanted and they were they
were ahead of the day they were the
pioneers and so you you just soak it all
up and you learn to read a room that's
what you do you learn to read a room and
you you learn to if there's you know I'm
I'm very sensitive to people empathetic
I think and and it for me it was really
important as well
and I it is really important just to
treat everyone with respect no matter
whether they're craft people or the
people you know who were paying my bill
you know yeah well I think that that's
that must be part and parcel of your
your kind of longevity recipe right it's
a it's a I mean fashion is a youth
obsessed yeah culture and business yeah
you've been you've been doing this for
decades you still book and you still
work yeah
um I mean you're unbelievably handsome
and we all know that you're a beautiful
man John But ultimately I have to
believe that you you know people want to
hire people they like to work with yeah
but they've worked they've had good
experiences working with in the past and
you know fashion I'm sure is you know
sort of spitting out people all the time
who are you know handsome or beautiful
or what have you but are difficult or
not team players and don't respect the
process or whatever it is so the fact
that you're still so you know actively
you know engaged in this world is you
know a tribute I think more to your kind
of life philosophy or the manner in
which you treat people I mean I've been
around you enough to know you know what
a lovely human you are and how curious
you are about other people and the kind
of level of respect and care that you
inject all of your interactions with
yeah I mean I think I think it's
um
I think it was always for me one of the
one of the reasons was I just wanted to
rebook and I knew that was really
interesting so that was almost conscious
so there was an element of that which
was you know being a Salesman I think
that came from my market days and I
think but all I mean though to me I
looked at magazines and when I was in
Italy all these Americans were there and
I haven't really met Americans before
and they were all jimmed up and
six-packed and everything else and that
was so not me we were the sort of you
know we prided ourselves out my little
sort of Motley Crew of Europeans our our
little tribe on you know Richard Burson
and Peter O'Toole and drinking and going
out and you know we don't go to the gym
and all that sort of stuff which you
know now I'm the age I am I'm like okay
I should have maybe looked after myself
a bit more but um
but no it was always about that it's
always about
feeling good it's always about raising
the day we're really fortunate to do
what we do and and to have the life and
the places I've been and the people I've
met and it was just well I've got to
have a good attitude with that there's
always going to be better looking
there's always going to be someone new
on the Block but for me it was always
about connecting with the people on more
than just the superficial level I wanted
to really engage I Am Naturally curious
in people's stories so you know I'm you
know I'm just grateful that I'm here I
literally went from a young stud to a
Granddad you know I've done it all and
it's kind of ridiculous but and I can't
believe it I'm still here doing it
occasionally but I really have a lot of
joy in doing it now because I can help
the young kids and I can tell the
stories and it's different of course but
you know you can you can you can uh
it's just great I I feel it's great to
be involved in a collaborative creative
pursues and I think everyone who comes
into that Circle should be respected and
should be given sort of uh you know
given time and attention you know I
think it's I think you know we all we
all have a good time yeah everyone's
gonna remember it and you remember those
moments 20 years later someone will come
up to me and say oh thank you you gave
me this advice and it really helps and I
can't remember it but at the time
because you had a genuine connection it
meant something part of that is a
reaction to the fact that you didn't
have anybody like that when you were a
young person yeah obligation yeah I do I
do I do and I think part of My Success
dare I say as a performer was in a way
probably to
get a validation or get an approval you
know and and maybe that's why I was
really searching for it a lot and so I
managed to take care of everybody but
yes I think it definitely has something
to do with it as well as wanting to have
an extraordinary life yeah and now you
have Mr feel good as an outlet to
express that Curiosity which I think is
pretty cool and probably on some level
also like looking for mentors or
introducing an audience to people who
can be mentors like I think about this
podcast in a similar way and in thinking
about the lack of mentors that you had I
was reflecting on my own life thinking
who were my mentors and realizing that
you know I had a great dad but it's
often not the parent that you're looking
to to be the mentor and I had a bunch of
really unhealthy people who were giving
me not great advice as a young person
despite having a lot of opportunity like
I didn't have a really good Mentor and I
thought maybe this podcast is like this
blatant desire to like you know continue
to find those people that I didn't have
when I was when I was younger yeah and
Mr feel good obviously feels similar in
that regard yeah I mean Mentor it's just
such a vital part for a healthy mental
and physical life as well and I didn't
have a mental like say but I I made a I
made a I really remember consciously
especially after my father died
making all my best friends and I had a
wide circle of friends I was really more
so engaged with trying to find a sort of
hybrid of what a man should be so I I
got very close with all their fathers
and they were all amazing you know
someone taught me about humor someone
taught me about you know being
professional about dress what you how
you presented yourself someone you know
made me want to read so I I sort of
picked out this uh made this sort of
imaginary
perfect man but a pretty good man to get
to navigate life from that and uh
and that was extraordinary but at the
same time
there was a sort of you know there was a
I was dealing with this grief of losing
a parent without any kind of support and
and so that was I didn't want to
infringe on my friend's relationships
with their Dads as well you know and uh
but the misser feel good is really a
yeah it's a culmination born out of sort
of not being able to travel anymore and
knowing all these people and having all
these adventures and really being
interested in people and in you know
ways of thinking and of ways of living
and making money and everything else and
and it was really
designed as a the Genesis of it was as a
pushback to the toxicity that we all
expect were collectively experiencing
during the pandemic yeah and the
political division but also just wanting
to really put something out there that
was positive that was helpful that
unified people that and especially with
men you know I grew up with all women
but I'm equally happy in a car or a room
full of men
um but I was always quite open in my
environment as well growing up talking
about things that mattered feelings and
you know
um
it was kind of encouraged and I thought
it was really important for men
especially to communicate properly and I
don't care
you know what your sexuality is what
your socioeconomic background is your
education I just think that if we all
sat around a campfire in the Mojave
Desert under a beautiful sky we're going
to have a beautiful experience together
and we're going to learn something so
with Mr feel good I continue to do it
and enjoy it and thrive in it because
I'm learning so much from the people
it's like you it's like you you get
these people in front of you and you can
actually talk to them and learn stuff
and it's and it's just so inspiring to
me but at the same time it's so useful
and as a father of three kids two boys
and a girl
um you know it is it takes a village you
know it takes a village to raise your
kids and I'm really aware of that and
I'm really grateful for that as well
because you know they look at me like
Dad what you're doing you know oh yeah
dad you know ah dad you know but then if
I talk to a good friend of mine and he
drops a little bit of advice you see
them open up and I'm so grateful it's
funny how that works right yeah like
everything I do my kids think it's
cringe-worthy yeah of course right it
doesn't it doesn't imagine being a male
model
yeah the level of [__] that they must
get oh man yeah no epic right yeah it is
it is but I think they you know they
know when to stop because they'll get
too sensitive and insecure and they're
like back off from dead you know so Mr
feel good is this pandemic baby like you
birthed this thing when we're all locked
down and I'm sure you're you know trying
to figure out how to exert your creative
voice in a moment in which we can't
travel and all of that and I do think
that there's something
really necessary and Urgent about
speaking to the mental health of of of
of men like there is despite look
there's a lot of progress and things
have changed quite a bit but there there
aren't quite
the level of resources that are
available for women in that regard and
I'm not sure there really is that sense
of permissiveness that is required for
men to engage in a vulnerable and real
way with what we've sort of been taught
our whole lives to kind of repress like
that advice to you know yeah look at
your dad's Tombstone and just push it
down and move along you know like that
is still probably the the reigning
Paradigm when it comes to men and mental
health and if there's anything you know
that I'm trying to speak to it's it's
it's kind of upending that Paradigm and
and that feels very much at the heart of
what you're you know attempting to do as
well yeah I mean it's what you do it's
what I do it's you know there's some
great people out there doing it I think
it's vital work for us all to sort of
own every aspect of ourselves and try
and deal with it so yeah no absolutely
yeah but you can't deliver that message
in a clinical way and I like how you've
wrapped it in fashion and music with
beautiful photography and storytelling
and kind of this uh very specific uh
interview style where you kind of ask
the same questions to all of these
guests so you're delivering a certain
kind of product that feels more like a
glossy fashion magazine but with a
certain heart and intentionality about
it that doesn't exist in that world yeah
and and that was really born out of when
Pete Sampson my co-founder of Mr feel
good who's 20-year veteran Fleet Street
journalist you know
[Music]
um
very smart and I knew him because his
wife worked with my wife uh creatively
and he so we knew each other a little
bit but he came up to me just he called
me just before lockdown and said can I
have a word with you I want to talk to
you about something I said sure I was
interested I met him for lunch
and he sort of had a rough idea of what
Mr feel good was he sort of conceived it
and he liked my writing and Instagram or
something like that because it was
honest I suppose and there was something
to it but really I remember it so
clearly I was shopping around this uh
this thing that I'd written and produced
an art show and at the time just before
lockdown that I'd been working on for a
couple of years but he he it was the way
he spoke to me and the way he was
vulnerable he you know just stopped
drinking and he was tired of doing the
same old thing all the time being this
you know this sort of
reporter that went around the world and
a little bit of sensationalism in there
you know is that sort of vibe and he was
so honest when he talked to me when he
sat opposite me he was so open and he
was vulnerable and he was not a guy
usually I'd see him at airports and we'd
you know smoking cigarettes having a
drink at the bar and to see him in this
position it just really really spoke to
me and I said well let's develop it
let's play Let's see what we can do I
love the idea and event originally he
was just gonna sort of use me as a
frontman as I've been used all these
times and I could come in and come out
and you know it was a sort of vanity
project but the more I thought about it
and exchange ideas with him the more I
realized that it was something of value
and it could be something that could
really help and also I could
you know I could utilize my experience
on every level in various careers or you
know professions and the people the
relationships I built which really for
me you know the in the 90s when I was in
LA and I was at you know really shooting
everything
people used to talk about networking and
I hated that phrase I hated that word
because it sense felt so insincere right
it felt like it was Sleazy and you're
just going after something to get
something yeah and I just you know I
don't want to be I don't know why and
but I just felt it was a bit dirty and I
wanted to have a proper conversation I
wanted to connect with people and if I
said I'd do something for someone I
would absolutely do it and I would today
it's just it it doesn't I don't second
guess that at all so I don't know I
think I think uh
I don't even know sorry I've lost you've
lost me yeah just the the idea of like
uh I think what you're getting at is you
have Decades of relationships that
you've built organically
um with with the best of intentions over
many years and now you have this digital
media project you know idea that you're
trying to birth into the world and you
can tap into all of these people with
whom you have tremendous Goodwill
because you've worked with them for many
years so you're able to like get these
incredible photographers and you have
access to talent and Studio space and
all these sorts of things because it's
sort of like I look at it like well I've
been doing this 10 years and now we're
in a place where we can have this studio
and I can have people I love people yeah
but you come out of the gate and it's
like this is an expensive proposition
you know like you're gonna you wanna
work with like top tier people and
deliver at the highest level like that
doesn't happen cheaply yeah and and uh
you know it's one thing to develop an
audience over time where where you can
monetize it in a certain way and how to
square the budget but you've bit off a
lot and it's ambitious right so I'm
interested in the business side of it
and how you're making that work I mean I
know you have Brands now who are coming
in who are supporting you and and and
you know the legacy of your your career
has uh you know allowed people to step
in and who believe in you and who are
willing to support you yeah I mean I'm
really fortunate and also I'm married to
someone within the industry and and you
know we've forged genuine friendships
and I hope respect for certainly I have
respect for the people around me you
know over over three decades and and so
and also we're at a period where you
know photographers and teams want to
work and they want to show their work
without too much interference and I
choose those people or those people come
to me and you know because I want them
to Flat to Blossom as well so I want to
give them
space and and a sort of page to do what
they want to do and we're just I'm
really grateful for all the teams I mean
you know I I didn't think it had
happened like this but I I kind of
had confidence in in my relationships
and once we'd done a couple of issues
and you know I opened with an interview
with all the girls from the freedom
video agreed it was the 30th anniversary
and I sort of tentatively you know
texted uh Christy Turlington and asked
her if she would be interested she was
straight in and brought all the other
girls in and spoke to Tatiana and they
were so supportive you know and that was
just like that's very tantalizing where
to launch yeah you know people are going
to be interested in reading about them
yeah it was it was the 30th anniversary
of this iconic video so as far as
business goes yeah we're getting
advertising it's starting to come in
which is amazing
um but we're also you know we're finding
our way you know we're designed we're
still we're trying to determine and I
say this and I feel vulnerable saying it
but we're trying to determine where we
are what exactly we will be
um I just know that we're we're a
community that's building of great
creatives but everyone is welcome having
a great conversation and trying to learn
and support one another and you know
pull down Prejudice and sort of have an
open mind I just want to learn and I I
feel like all the people that are around
us working with us and for us are sort
of in that same vein you know and I mean
I get letters every week from really
good photographers and creative people
wanting to work with us it's just a case
of you know we're not a big operation
right now so we're doing every single
job and that's another thing that I it
was a learning curve for me I I had to I
mean and you helped me so much in this
in your conversations because I had to
break through so many Comfort zones
because I was the guy that was always
helping everyone out and doing that
that's my natural you know personality I
think but also I suddenly had to work on
a deadline I had to be accountable I had
to race every week you know I had to
trust that I could walk onto a set
having been the model the subjects and
direct the set and make sure everyone
did a great job and they kind of you
know be the creative director on that so
use everything that I'd seen first hand
from the best professors in the cultural
business and just trust that I could you
know I could execute this and make the
person feel good and relax and know that
I'm after the truth of what they've got
to say because that's what I value most
so you know it's a learning curve that
continues to this day I mean it's yeah
it's never ending well I think I think
and I say this all the time it's
important especially in the the kind of
nascent stages of anything creative
that's ongoing like this is remaining
open and flexible and and being in that
space of letting it tell you what it
wants to be like not being rigid and
saying this is what we're doing like
okay here's what we're doing now but
let's learn like oh maybe it would be
cool if we move over here or we do this
and I've seen some Evolution already
with you I think one of the things that
we talked about early was originally it
was it was it was photographs and and
written material but you've evolved into
like you put it out as a podcast and you
have YouTube videos like you kind of
have to be everywhere now and I think we
talked about how important video is like
you can't there's no way around it like
you have to make that part of the thing
and that's an expensive proposition you
know especially in the early you know
phases of what you're trying to do
yes it is and yes you know you can you
know and obviously being a I kept a
journal for 10 years but apart from that
and I was a big reader as I said
so I was intimidated by what I read so
that stopped me from writing so much you
know so but going through this process
of having to write and be accountable
um has been extraordinary and
um
yeah I just I I I don't know we're just
doing the best we can every every day
and you know
slaying the dragons as they come but I'm
I I'm I don't know whether I'm at that
point where you are where you just kind
of go with it I'm still like trying to
keep all these uh plates spinning and
have some degree of control
um just because there's so much to do
you know I do everything so with a with
you know with Pete of course and Allison
as well but
um
it's I saw your thing the other day
about 10 years your 10-year anniversary
and I thought wow I'm just over two
years in now of doing this 24 7 of
working on this you know night and day
really and I thought oh my goodness it's
a long way to go I've got a long way to
go you have to create some kind of
sustainability for yourself yeah because
you can't
you can't transmit something you haven't
got and it's part of the message or a
big part of the message is self-care
mental health Etc if you're on a track
to burning out and you're not able to
like exercise that yourself then you
can't transmit that message that's what
you preach and it's something I've you
know I've run up against this I'm sure
if it becomes very difficult like all
this Wellness is making me unwell right
all this all this talk about mental
health is is diseasing my mind right
like how do you strike that balance for
yourself as an entrepreneur who's you
know it's Scrappy and you gotta like
make it happen it falls on your
shoulders and all of that yeah I mean
you you the what the way you put
everything out just blows my mind you
know it's tons of people helping me now
I know but you know you've it's evolved
into it yeah I know and and it's very
very impressive and effective with us
it's literally you know
I shoot it on iPhones for the most part
and I send it to my nephew who's a film
you know an actor and a film shooter in
London and he edits it with me or with
us and uh it's very Scrappy as you know
because I interviewed you it was one
iPhone then and I still haven't gotten
around to edit that yeah
um but but I understand the value so
yeah so the value of you know I was
writing these tomes to my interviews at
the beginning
and you know Pete's sort of saying John
15 000 words is a bit too many let's
bring it down to 1500 or 3 000 and I was
so protective because it was really
important for me to get the essence of
the human being and Pete's a lot more
thank goodness he's a great editor and
he's pragmatic and it's factual and is
you know is to the point whereas I'm
really a bit more
I don't know emotional and I want to
really I feel I need to connect with
this human being and I and I feel a
great responsibility to the people that
I interview as well as I'm sure you do
yeah and so video is a way I think it's
just of the Zeitgeist now it's of the
movement people get their information
that way so we we're we're working on
that now and improving that and you know
it's just the question of time and being
able to do everything and at the same
time bring up a family and you know and
provide for yourself and
excuse me
um just crack on you know yeah so I'm
learning as I go I really am one foot in
front of the other
trying to keep calm at many times trying
to learn how to deal in uh look after
myself within the chaos which is
challenging you know it really is
challenging so
um but like you say yeah you've got to
you've got to be well to really with
Integrity speak about wellness and hope
to help other people right yeah I mean
for sure and listen you know I say that
as somebody who's constantly out of
balance like thank you anything that
I've that I have mastered by any stretch
of the imagination I just know from
experience and being you know massively
out of balance at times you know the
pressures that that create and the level
of you know dissonance that you feel as
this person who has a sense of
responsibility to the audience you know
so like if you're out of balance then
yeah how powerful is this message that
you're putting out yeah it's going to
fall flat yeah like on a spiritual
energetic level yeah right it's not
integrated it's not you know it's not in
lockstep with who you are so staying on
top of that I think is really important
and I think that goes back for to what
we were talking about in pictures in in
Stills and in videos for me I always
knew that if you had a good time and you
really engaged with somebody and you got
lost and you weren't afraid to be a fool
and to be Daft and to you know my
responsibility especially as I got older
was I really wanted to take care of the
people who were in the photograph with
me I wanted to make them comfortable
with this girl or a kid or baby or
whatever else or another man you know
you want to and I think if you do that
properly and you do that with
genuine Integrity that transmits to the
person who's looking at that picture and
that's just the way it is and so
you know I always want to no matter how
tired I am no matter how worn out I am I
want to be present you know I want to be
I want to be real yeah the uh we talked
about
um the other day when we got together uh
I was asking you about
how you define success for yourself and
and family really is at the center of
all of this for you right yeah and Mr
Feelgood is kind of uh uh a way of
honoring that on some level tangentially
like what's important to you yeah in the
work that you do and how you live your
life yeah it was really it was it was
crystal to clear to me at an early age
that I wanted to be present for my kids
as a father I wanted to really
experience the full gamut of what being
a father is very rock and roll John I
know it isn't I know it isn't I know it
isn't it but it isn't no it isn't but it
really I think I think I was probably so
damaged from it or not really the trauma
of losing your yeah I think that was it
and I
I just really felt that if I didn't no
matter and I was really on a you know a
high with my life and my work and my
career at this point but I just thought
if I didn't have a family especially
with my wife
you know and have children
um and really put my time and energy
into that it sounds so sanctimonious I
don't mean to be sanctity it sounds so
but it was really clear to me that that
was important to me I wanted to create
what I didn't have I chose a partner who
was came from the
contrasting background who had that and
it was really important that I live and
my kids live in as much as a drama-free
Zone as possible where we could just
you know breathe and and go after what
we want and have a good life so that was
really clear to me and that kept me that
kind of kept me grounded I think I mean
but how did you do that in the context
of a career where you have to go away
come back it's not a nine to five thing
where you drive down the street to an
office yeah come home at dinner time
every day I think I think it helps in a
way I think because my wife traveled as
well and worked for magazines for Vogue
and for Harper's Bazaar for years and
still does and not for them but for
other other mags but um I think it sort
of it enriched the relationship ending I
go away and I have friends all over the
world that have these rich creative sort
of experiences and I got to breathe and
explore and I came back and that was my
story to tell you know that was my way
of then giving everything when I was at
home and everything when I was away
um and being this like citizen of the
world yeah and it was really you know it
was good and I think it was inspiring
for my kids as well to an extent or they
grew up seeing this dad who was
traveling here but Ali my wife used to
go away two months of a year to do the
collections and go New York Paris Milan
extra
Etc and I would I would try and stay at
home and we had help at that time but I
was really conscious of being there and
you know I really wanted to be a great
dad I don't know
how what are the ages now you have one
your son you have a son at NYU right no
he's back he's he he uh graduated he was
at NYU Clive Davis School of Music
That's Cooper He's 26. uh Elliot's 23
um and Marley is in New York she's the
only one away and she's uh 19. wow so
you know and and you know
they're they're incredible kids they
really are they're incredible people
um
they're better than what I could have
expected you know I think it's down to
my misses more than me I think I'm the
crazy one
um but they're amazing people they're my
the best people I know they're
extraordinary people don't get me
started because they'll you know I'll
get my hankies out yeah well and and so
from a dad perspective like what do you
think you did right
no I don't know what didn't I do wrong
um
I think I really don't know that's such
a big question I think
the way you treat your partner they pick
up on that the way you um treat other
people they pick up on that I think the
way you deal with stress which which at
times especially when I we came back to
America
you know it's quite difficult for a
little while
um
they pick up on that and I think you
just I think you really and again I
think it's really important to learn to
listen
and to you know especially now
especially when we're on phones all out
all you know all day long and there's so
many distractions I think it's really
important to sit down at a dinner table
and listen and have them with other
grown-ups when they're a little and you
know our house was the house that all
the kids friends came to sat around our
table and they all felt very
you know free and able to speak
um you know talk about anything they
wanted to talk about because I had a
friend when I was eight years old who
invited me to his house and his family
sort of took me in and they you know
allowed me to do that and that was
subconsciously that became our home so I
don't know what it is I think it's
partly who they are anyway what they're
born with
and it's not perfect by any means but
it's just a work in progress and and
ultimately
ultimately it's about love you know it's
about being there for somebody I mean my
it it's it's just being there knowing
when to step back and let them be them
and let them Express themselves and let
them you know confide up in you or not
confide in you give them that space and
respect you know that's kind of what it
feels like we do yeah and on on some
level
modeling yeah quote unquote yeah a
healthy masculinity right and and
masculinity being kind of you know it's
interesting like I want to dive into
this idea of masculinity because what
you do for a living and what you get
paid to do is a version of modeling a
type of masculinity that like spills out
into
popular culture and then Mr feel good is
a way of modeling like a you know and
that's a voiceless thing is like there's
no you don't have a voice in that you
have it you have an image you know it's
true right yeah no it's true yeah so so
Mr Feelgood is almost like uh the
antidote to that I I want to express
myself and here's how I think about
masculinity in a healthy way in the
context of a culture in which there's
too much toxic masculinity like how do
you think about that issue and how you
kind of shoulder the responsibility for
for being an example of of you know a
healthy male in a world in which you
think a lot about mentors and you know
uh the kind of message that you're
putting out into the world
I think it's
um you know also with the work I do and
did for so long you know it's I didn't
have a voice but
um but I did have a voice in a way
between the clicks of the camera I never
I rarely
Felts insecure because I wouldn't allow
myself to feel insecure because I knew I
was a center of attention and and
perhaps I clothed that in a way that you
know
um
maybe who I was on set and made me want
to get the approval to some degree and
make everyone feel good
um it's
you know it's funny I've just shot these
five gentlemen for Mr feel good and
they're from all different walks of life
and it's incredibly incredible how some
of them are very awkward in front of the
camera and I understand that
um
but um and they all say wow it's really
hard work I didn't realize how how hard
the work was and it doesn't seem like it
is from the outside but when you're sort
of firing on 12 cylinders and you really
want to be present it it it's it's it's
proper graft it's proper work they all
confirmed that this last week which is
interesting
um so but yes I mean Mr feel good really
was a vehicle for me to use what I've
learned and express and learn more about
having a voice and having a purpose and
doing something which has you know
foundations that hopefully will spit
spill out and support other people who
are feeling lost especially men you know
yeah it's it we try and make it that
it's not too woo-woo we want it to be
pragmatic we want to I mean at the
moment we're gratefully
you know interviewing the Fantastic
actors but I really want to I you know
I'm really interested in talking to
people who aren't famous I just
everyone's got a story and I just think
it's really important to have a
conversation that's yeah I mean you have
an Eclectic mix of people like you had
Scott Callaway on it obviously you know
cares a lot about these issues yeah
these respect to young males and yeah
what's happening and even
um you know the architect who built yeah
what is that BB like that architecture
you built like mini shells yeah right
Robert Downey Jr and it's a it's a
Sustainable Building Material amazing
very cool amazing amazing men amazing
yeah and they you know so so I'm trying
to get broader on that and I want more
well how do you like make that selection
or curate that
you think about as well like when you're
thinking like who can I get or who
should I get like I just know
in the evolution of this show it went
from me begging borrowing and stealing
just to convince anybody to sit down
with me to now thinking more about like
who's it's not like who who wants to do
it or who I can get it's like who's the
right person yeah of course yeah well
for me I mean it's you know the
beginning it was just who I knew and
then it was people that I really had my
eyes on and admired like Scott
um like you and just you know it was a
case of actually finding a way and I'm
Relentless when it comes to that I'm
very good at writing letters I've got I
could have a whole book on the Love
Letters I've sent to people and I mean
it I I mean I really do I want to sit
down and talk to these people and I
think if you're persistent and I am and
if you uh if you think they'll add value
to the the sort of um
the big picture then you know I'll I'll
just DM them I'll find a friend who
knows them I'll find out who their agent
is you know
oh there's some great people out there
that I'm desperate to talk to you know
that I really want to talk to so you
just find a way if you've no you know if
you've got the will you find the way so
um I think going back to the sort of
masculinity thing I think that's
something
that today I'm still trying to work with
and I'm trying to find
you know
you can't be all things to all people
but I'm trying to find ways that um
I can expose or not expose I can
celebrate I like to say that help me and
that thus help the audience at Mr feel
good so I'm really looking to have those
conversations and to learn I want to
learn you know I'm I'm my mum's 88 she's
relentlessly curious so she really is
you know and and I've inherited that and
I just this there's so much out there
and
um and there's so much I don't know I
really don't know and I'm trying to
figure out the best way to live with the
most amount of Peace of love and and and
a growing kind of satisfaction that
we're actually doing something of value
yeah does that make sense yeah for sure
you know look we're we're of a certain
age we're Gen X guys right
um
right that's [__] cool it is cool
yeah man yeah for sure it's very it's
very not Gen X to be you know kind of
vulnerable in where your emotions on
your sleeve which is you know kind of
what I do like you know to be Gen X is
to be disaffected and to be ironic yeah
and all of that um which we can be yeah
right we can turn that on we're grown-up
Jacks right yeah um but reflecting on
you know the generations that are that
are coming up underneath us I think the
idea like young young men like it is a
more confusing time like we grew up in
an analog world yeah right and that
we've we're one one of the last
generations of people to kind of
Traverse from analog to digital yeah but
our formative years were pre-computer
completely right
um and now uh I think we're in a
confusing state for a lot of men where
there's expectations
for them to you know be strong be the
provide like to kind of like inhabit the
traditional sense of what it is to be
masculine and yet also to be the
sensitive person the person who goes to
all the you know school events and you
know on weekdays at two o'clock in the
afternoon or and who you know is caring
and like like somebody who has to fire
on all cylinders right and there's an
expectation level that I think is
difficult for
you know anybody to live up to
essentially and when you kind of step
down into even the younger Generations
who are dealing with you know how to how
to
how to date and that's all digital now
with these apps and all that kind of
stuff and you know this is something
Scott Galloway talks quite a bit about
like
I think it's really hard right and and
you know we're we're at a certain age
where we don't have direct experience
with those sorts of things so how do you
think about you know lending a hand or
being a mentor or communicating helpful
information to that person who is trying
to navigate you know those all of those
landmines
it's tough it's tough
um I think
I think our sons have to and their
tribes have to learn to
be vulnerable and
be connected as a community and to not
have too many expectations because there
are a lot of expectations on them it is
a different world I think it's very
difficult I think
I think they're also very smart a lot of
them and they can figure it out and
things that I worry about for them they
aren't even worrying about because
they're if they're focused if they if
they're fortunate enough to have
something they love to do have a purpose
or a goal or be passionate about
something I think that helps them a lot
to direct their focus and to move
forward in the as they go into Life as a
young adult but you can't manufacture
that for anybody no especially your kids
no unfortunately you can expose them to
lots of different things and just hope
that something connects with them and
lights them up in that way yeah it's
true
um I mean it's a it's a work in progress
you know and it's it's I think all we
try and do is be open but provide a safe
space where they can explore those kind
of feelings and worries and advise them
on what we know and what we've
experienced in an ever-changing world
where they can then sort of bespoke it
if they're able and all my kids
personally our kids are you know they're
pretty the greatest
really one of the greatest things of my
life is that
my kids know who they are and I think
that's you know a lot more than I did at
that age the I think the French
comfortable in their own skin that's
that's like you're on the you're on the
10-yard line if you have that yeah you
know yeah and I'm really I I stand back
and I watch them and I observe them in
company and the way they
sort of address the issues of the day
their own personal challenges and I feel
really just so grateful that they've got
that that and I think it probably comes
from my wife's family side
um but I think uh
that's that's a marvelous thing that's a
real blessing I think it's tough out
there I really think it's tough out
there and I by no means have an answer
for you that's eloquent or or rooted for
you yet in all honesty but I also want
to engage and as we grow younger people
into Mr feel good I want to bring them
into their sort of fold and have them
write for me and a couple of them do
already and just sort of the idea of
having sitting around a table with these
kids you know
12 men I want you to do this with me at
some point but 12 really interesting men
who can sit round and we can talk and we
can listen
and I think Community when you build
community and especially of men
you know
I think that's a really powerful thing I
think to sit and to be listened and to
be heard is a really powerful thing and
especially in a circle of men who are
who are trying to do the right thing who
are who are trying to calibrate this
ever-changing sort of world I think
that's really vital
um but I certainly don't have the
answers but I'm
I'm
determined to try and help and
contribute in some way yeah I mean
vital's the right word I mean I've been
lucky enough to be parts of groups like
that you know through recovery and also
through other
therapeutic modalities and it's been
absolutely transformative for me it's
amazing but I'm also aware that it's not
the experience of most people most men
right and I think a lot of men
suffer in silence yeah and they just
carry on and push it all down until
something one day you know breaks or
explodes and I think that's the more
typical experience and to the extent
that you know there are solutions for
people who are in that state like I want
to be participating in yeah in that
because I you know I think it's chronic
honestly and there is an epidemic of
mental health disorders that you know
it's not unique to men but I think there
is something about men where it's not
talked about to the extent that it
should be and getting help
is not as permissive as it should be and
it should be and we should all you know
we should take time to reach out to our
community and put the effort and the
energy into building these sort of
um
creating these situations where we can
all exchange where you know we can sort
of feel safe to talk about I mean the
whole vulnerable thing that's a really
sort of mysterious one for me I know
it's important and I know it's valuable
and I never really
ah recognize my own
cute vulnerability until I started doing
Mr feel good I had episodes but
consistently being accountable and
having to do this after having had an
agent who just said this is the flight
get this is how much there you are you
know yeah and I and and I I I I still
I'm still really curious about the whole
vulnerable thing and you know when to be
restrained when to be open what value
will that give the person I'm sitting
with you know and I still my Yorkshire
roots are like yo man up man up you know
don't talk well there's certainly don't
be soft you know and all that stuff but
you won't survive you won't survive
you'll you'll be a you know you'll
you'll
self-medicate you'll drink you'll
whatever your drug of choice is or
you'll just implode yeah and you'll
freak out you'll do something stupid and
I I think we have to change that maybe
it's an education you know maybe it's
having people like you and Scott myself
perhaps you know going in and talking
about this actually uh delivering uh uh
um you know a a a lessons on this sort
of thing you know actually going into
the education system and and I do think
you know doing Retreats with fellas with
men is really good young guys and and
older guys and I think there's a lot to
be said
for taking Sage advice from those who
came before us you know even though they
lived in a in a in a more closed-off
sort of or a more
one-dimensional idea of masculinity I I
was brought up to respect my elders and
I was lucky because when my parents
divorced I go and see my father and he'd
always do Meals on Wheels and he'd take
me around delivering food to the elderly
and most of these guys had just come out
and ladies had come out of the second
world war they were the last and it was
fascinating to engage with their sort of
stoicism and their dignity and I think
you know I learned a lot about listening
to people then and and uh
I think I think we have to do something
about it I think we have to engage I
think we have to sort of join forces and
you know
create something that really does
because the important thing is a lot of
people sort of start doing these things
but it's the it's it's being there for
the long ride which is important yeah
and especially in this day and age when
everything's so disjointed and quick and
we're overcome with sort of information
I think to be consistent is really a
great quality to have and I think you
know if you if you're mentoring someone
you're in it for life yeah you know you
should be and you'll reap benefits you
know but but really it's you you can't
just do it for a a day you can't give a
bit of advice and think it's done you
have to be consistent yeah and you know
set against a culture in which
everything is ephemeral like everything
disappears like you know tissue paper on
fire from one day to the next yeah the
idea of consistently showing up and that
accountability piece I think is super
important and listen you touched on
listening I mean I think that is it the
key Cornerstone of everything I think
we've star our appreciation for
listening and I think we're seeing that
in the the denigration of the national
conversation and our inability to kind
of you know sit with people who who see
the world differently from us as our
information silos continue to separate
increasingly and it's a confusing time
right and and to the extent that being
vulnerable is somehow Curative it's also
important to you know check your
motivations behind that
um that vulnerability because there is
something called performative
vulnerability that we're seeing on
social media and I don't think that that
is helpful either it's sort of like what
is helpful to to somebody else in in how
I communicate from a place of honesty
and integrity versus let me tell you
some crazy story that is horrific and
embarrassing for the purpose of of just
you know shock value or you know
creating attention around yourself yeah
yeah yeah no I think
um I think it's a day by day Moment by
moment
um
um challenge to be present you know to
be really present with somebody to
listen to somebody to
um
social media man I mean it's it's a
tough one it's a tough one and it it's
it's great in many ways but
you know being a father of a daughter
you know my boys aren't really they're
not at all involved but my daughter's
young and she's a brilliant and you know
to see what they go through really when
they engage with it it's it's it's tough
you know so
it's
I just think ultimately
we've got to
keep being present and available and and
listening to people and Trust
that will
find the seeds of something that will
help
um all of us benefits I think all of us
whatever age we are it's tiresome
it's exhausting and I think we've just
got to part of our lives have to be
grounded part of our lives have to be
for us to survive for us to thrive parts
of our Lives just have to be connected
and on a really you know
um authentic level of of
you know the only thing I know is love
you know that's the thing that always
comes back to me the only thing I know
is
really the love I have for my family for
my friends for nature for music for
people who I admire and that's sort of
the uncertainty for me and I really
don't have the answers but I try and
go into the day every day I really do
with with that in mind knowing that I'll
get through knowing that I'll find a way
having hope with that which a lot of
kids struggle with of course and
um
and when I do that when I overcome my
fears or my doubts or my overthinking or
everything else I mean it always works
it always seems to give me a
energizes me in a way that I that makes
me feel good yeah you know Mr feel good
Mr feel good baby I don't know I don't
know it's it's kind of just come out of
it really
um it's it's you're a spiritual Seeker
though too right like I always know that
you're super curious about all different
forms of of spiritual wisdom weren't you
weren't you doing a project with satguru
or a documentary or something like that
yeah no well I did I I did a retreat
with sad Guru and and
um you know I was into yoga I mean it
started very early when I was literally
12 years old at the school in England
they gave you a Gideon Bible and at the
back of the Gideon Bible there was a
calendar schedule to read a verse or ten
verses every night and in a year you'd
read the whole thing and I read it every
single religiously no pun intended every
single night and I was really interested
in that and then we moved into a
different house and my next door
neighbors there are three boys and a
single mum and they were Jehovah's
Witnesses so I took on being a Jehovah's
Witness at the age of 12 or 13 and went
door to door knocking on the door yeah
it was yeah I was and and it was it was
it was it was my my sister
got into a car accident and needed a
blood transfusion and that kind of that
kind of turned me away plus I got to 14
and 15. I like girls you know and I was
like okay this is a bit too you know too
restricting for me
um but I was naturally a seeker and I am
to this day and and and so you know I I
did various things I read many many
books uh on various religions and well
Carl Young and Buddhism and Zen and you
know Hinduism everything I was just
really like a sponge wanted to take it
take it in
um with sack Guru it was just really
extraordinary because a friend of mine
um practice with him regularly and she
she invited me to see him speak and
actually when I saw him speak I wasn't
didn't didn't fix me you know it didn't
it was It was a
a certain set of people and I thought it
was it wasn't all the artifice around it
yeah I sat at the feet
I don't I'm not with sakuru but lots of
other yeah people from that kind of
world and universe and there is
something about all the you know energy
around that person that's difficult to
kind of get past it was and and Gage
like is this real yeah is this wisdom
legitimate is this an artifice like what
is actually going on here yeah it was
really interesting I mean doing the yoga
for I think we were doing it you know
four o'clock in the morning getting up
and doing it I'm not very flexible you
know my mum at 88 can touch your toes
after having both the hips and a week
after having a hips and I'm I did hot
yoga for four years I still can't touch
my toes you know
um that aspect of it was challenging but
also you know just trying to figure out
what was going on and
everything that you say it was the same
thing it was it was interesting and then
I I was really obsessed because I really
wanted to talk to him and I wanted to
know more so I reached out to someone at
own and we were
preparing to you know I mean Oprah
Oprah's thing yeah and we were preparing
to actually go and sort of you know get
in there and have me find out about this
and discover this and you know ask him
questions tough questions I think and
then I think Discovery came and bought
it out and it all fell to pieces and
that was that but
but you know my time with him and I I
want to interview him that's on the
cards
um was extraordinary in many ways you
know so you you you you learn from every
experience or I try and learn from every
experience that I have and everyone
who's sat in front of me and you know
there's no
there's no way there's no one way
there's it's it's a culmination of
everything that you absorb in the
environment around you and just trying
to focus on the best of that to help
Propel you through another day you know
I'll help you
feel more
equipped to help those around you does
that make sense yeah yeah yeah
you know I'm curious about what that
looks like for you now like how does
that translate into a daily practice hmm
uh you know what I'm or it doesn't it
does and it doesn't and I'm I'm you know
I mean you said earlier about when you
feel challenged you know I'm presuming
tell me correct me if I'm wrong that you
get on your bike or you go for a swim or
you go for a run and that's when you
feel you know I used to do it sort of on
my motorbike but it's not working at the
moment you know I did TM for two years
religiously twice a day and that was
really that started to get really good
but then I dropped it you did you got
the Mantra and the whole thing well I
got the man Mantra I did that and then
when did you where did you who did you
do the training with
um actually in Santa Monica
with Bob Roth no no no no no no no I did
it with this one gentleman it's actually
sorry it wasn't Santa Monica it was
Beverly Hills and I was really
determined to make this a part of my
life and I'm a massive David Lynch fan
yeah and at times it was wonderful
because my boys just naturally came and
started to do it with me and that was a
really beautiful thing to have in our
house to sit there for 20 minutes in
silence and that really opened their
eyes to that sort of practice and those
sort of uh
um learning those modalities to help
them improve their sort of well-being
and then I dropped out and then I forgot
my mantra
I was like what is it it was some kind
of about a year and a half I was very
busy man I was everywhere but it was it
was a mariner it was sort of is there
some sort of policy like when you forget
your password yeah you can retrieve it
you have it locked down somewhere yeah
no no so that's what you know so a sort
of year passed and I thought I've got to
get back into this because I've got to
carve myself some personal space every
day because otherwise I'm a headless
chicken you know yeah and so and I think
it was a Sanskrit word the original one
and you're not allowed to say which one
it was obviously and so I went back to
TMI contacted them and I said could I
could you give me another Mantra they
said oh you have to find the original
guy who initiated you so I found this
the guy who eventually he'd moved out of
La he'd gone down south and and I drove
there you know sort of Long Beach way
and I went that way and we went in and
he sort of renewed and we went through
the whole thing again and then he gave
me a a mantra and it wasn't Sanskrit at
all it was really rudimentary it was
like a you know I'm not gonna say but it
was there is a basic thing and it and
that made me realize that Within
that practice it's really the word is
just there to bring you back it's just a
grounder it's not got any magical
magical properties it's just a grounder
and that just just works with the sort
of neurochemistry of your of the way
your brain works and fires so
but again you know it's I carried for a
while and and then practiced for a while
and then life took over me and so now
I'm trying to
you know I'd love I'm ready to sort of
get on that thing again you know get on
there I want to I mean now literally I
get up at five in the morning and I go
and sit outside and I have an hour
quiet on my own and I write and or I
just I'm just grateful I just try and be
grateful for my family for a roof over
my head for food for my children for my
friends
and
um you know but I'd really I I need to
I do I do feel a longing to sort of have
something that can be with me
consistently forever you know that sort
of magic
practice or not magic practice but again
it's it's
owning the fact that you should look
after yourself you should look after
yourself you've got I mean even in the
shower I'm like I'm you know I'm 57
years old man I've been lucky and my
body's you know I'm no you know male
model with a six-pack but but I'm but
I'm you know probably the most
successful now no but you know but I'm I
I look at my body and it's a vehicle and
a vessel and I think
are we lucky
to be in this car this vehicle for all
these years and it's really worked
pretty well for me given you know the
amount of sort of hammering it's taken I
don't mean sort of through drink and all
the rest of it I'm talking about you
know just different plane time zones
just the the amount of energy that we
put out into the world every day and
there's things we deal with and the
plates were spinning and the sort of
Forward Motion the momentum of life I'm
really amazed that you know
and I'm really grateful touchwood that
I'm in you know good health yeah well I
think gratitude seems to come easy for
you that is a natural disposition yeah
that it's it's far more elusive for me
is it really it is like I could use a
gratitude accountability partner in the
way that perhaps you could use a
meditation accountability partner and I
really believe I believe like I'm happy
to be that person for you oh wow
gratitude is not something I connect
with naturally it requires a lot of
intentionality and effort on my part to
really
feel that in myself but I am very aware
of
of trying to bring trying to create
Integrity between how I'm living my life
and and how I'm expressing myself
publicly in the work that I do yeah um
and I really think that for you and this
is a reminder to myself as well that the
greater alignment that you can create
between those two things like if you can
really like dial up the meditation and
the self-care piece and all of that it
does translate into the like the success
and the extent to which Mr feel good
will connect in a meaningful way with an
audience is directly calibrated to you
know how much you are living those
principles in your own life for sure
right and this is something that's hard
right especially when you're up against
it and you would share like you were up
late last night trying to get this thing
completed and out and all of that like I
relate to all of that but but
um and and we get we get like calcified
or wed to like this it has to be done
like this and I'm the only one who knows
how to do it you probably have to stay
up all night and whatever I'm managing
yeah but like the the magic is in the
letting go and in the empowering of
other people and and in the um
like kind of the like prioritizing your
your your self-care over like those
little details that actually don't
matter yeah you know that's a that's a
it's tough yeah right yeah it is I can't
you see for me I'm so grateful for you I
really am I'm so grateful for what you
do in this world and the way you do it
and it you know I I
you've been an enormous sort of uh
Pioneer and uh
um leader in what you do because you're
so authentic and it surprises me that
you know you you're challenged by that
because
I feel like you're you know so when you
say that I like I get very defensive no
I feel it yeah I saw your body twitch
yeah comfortable for me no but after
what you've gone through and what you've
done with your life I feel that you
should very uncomfortably uncomfortable
being held out to being any kind of like
ideal or you know Paragon of any of
these Notions I hear that I get that
messy work in progress yeah well I'm in
your Club baby I'm the same I'm just
trying to figure it out I'm trying to
learn
I'm trying to balance I'm trying to walk
the walk you know
um
I think it's really important to look
after yourself and I'm most of the time
I'm running and doing other things you
know and I'm not I'm not prioritizing
I'm trying to work out that discipline
and to to Really accept it as something
that I can only be a a
genuine value if I live these principles
if I
um practice them and um and forgive
myself when I don't you know when I fall
fall off that's a massive thing that's
like vulnerability is self-love
self-forgiveness I mean self-love saying
that you know it still there's an echo
there a shadow of you know self-love you
know it's all about you know don't be so
selfish or don't be so stupid don't talk
about yourself flat come on crack on and
so I I think it's you know we just gotta
I just keep going and and uh I want to
get to a place where there's a little
more control but at the same time I
understand that there's so little
control really you can only just do the
best you can do yeah so how do you
balance the Ambitions that you have for
yourself creatively professionally with
Mr feel good versus like being really
grateful in the present moment and and
freeing yourself or unshackling yourself
from
a desire or you know a a sense that it
needs to be any different than it
already is
cool that's a big one
um because like your life's pretty good
yeah it does is mine yeah no it's good
but there's always room for growth and
you've got to make an effort you know
you've got to
I feel
um
we've got to also I think what we also
have to do is have a bit more laughter
you know in life I think we have to get
lost a bit as well but within the joy
that's healthy and that's you know and I
think that comes with being with people
as well I mean I've got so many people I
see who are so stressed friends and
people acquaintances and everyone needs
to just really relax a bit and have some
fun and have a giggle you know I mean
giggle therapy we should do giggle
therapy with some stand-up guys you know
and and and
we've we've got to
I've got to be I've got to learn to
let go more and allow for things to
happen and that is sometimes it's easy
and sometimes it's not but when I do it
generally it's just energizing and it's
brilliant and you feel good the other
day the next day you know you feel good
about what you do so it's a work in
progress a messy work in progress and
and there's no I've got no formula at
the moment we're a startup we're
grafting we're
moving sometimes I you know I question
it but I push through it because also
I've got two other people that are
working with this me and then this you
know we're an outlet for a lot of people
in different countries now and I think
that's you know you've got to stay in
the game and you've got to try and
evolve in a way that becomes lean and
more and more authentic and more and
more
of value and I mean real value I don't
mean dollars and cents I'm talking about
the real value of the stuff that we all
connect with and we're all looking for
and we all need yeah so that's
that's what I'm doing I've got no I wish
I had better answers for you but I'm
it's it's really beautiful answer it's
just really you know it's really a
I don't even want to say we're up
against it because I don't want to I
don't want to I don't want to sort of
put it in that that label on it but but
because we're not because we're here and
we're lucky and we should be grateful
because we've you know we're not in the
trenches we're we're not in the The
Trenches we're out here living the best
life we can for uh pursuing a dream and
an ambition and an intention and I think
we're we should be really grateful just
for that and for fresh air and you know
for the ocean and all that sort of stuff
um
but yeah I'm a work in progress I'm
trying to do the best I can I'm trying
to if if something tells me in my gut
that it's right
then I I follow it you know and whether
it's a conversation or you know an
action or I just really trust that and
have you always trusted that or have you
learned to trust it I think how do you
know when to trust it hmm that's a good
one my gut has been unreliable in the
past and the way I've thought about it
is the the trustworthiness of that gut
instinct
has a lot to do with it's it's back to
that Integrity thing like how much
is the way in which I'm living matching
up with the values that I aspire to
inhabit you know if I'm out of balance
with that then my instincts are probably
going to lead me towards a bad decision
versus wow wow you're so self-aware man
you're evolved yourself totally only
through making bad decisions and being
in pain I I assure you yeah but that's
just to be aware of that and to have the
support of your mentors you know I mean
I wish I would love to have mentors I
would love to be in that group of of
people that uh that allow for every
aspect of my character you can you can
all you have to do is you know drink
yourself into Oblivion destroy your life
first and then you will be welcome in I
guess well I don't drink anymore that's
been over two years now and that's
helped in a in a way but tell me about
that well I just I just you know no one
drinks in our house and uh my kids don't
drink and um my wife doesn't drink I
mean she's probably a five gin and
tonics in all the years I've known her
and I wasn't a big drinker but I I could
drink you know and it's part of the
culture I grew up in yeah um and then
when we went into lockdown I found
myself drinking a bottle of wine on my
own every night and apart from the fact
that it made me snore and that was kind
of pretty obnoxious I think for my wife
um
I just thought I'll stop you know I'll
give it a couple of days so
um
and I think also in all honesty I think
I was grumpy and I think I was probably
insensitive when I drank and I wasn't as
Jolly and life and soul of the party of
perhaps I thought I was and I realized
it wasn't fair especially when you're
locked you're incubated in this small
space and we didn't know what was going
on so I stopped on the 14th of June
2020. I think it was and I thought I'll
do it for a couple of you know days and
then it came to the weekend and then 11
days later it was I think you know I was
coming up to a birthday and I realized
that I hadn't not drunk on my birthday
for over 40 years I thought that's weird
so I got through that
and then I just sort of got into the
rhythm of it you know and I like the
idea that I had control over something
um
you know that that that benefited the
whole family and then when we started to
open up I went to a friend's house we
met you know with distance and masks and
we met outside and he has extraordinary
wine and and uh tequila
and he offered me both and I sort of was
about to and then I pulled back and said
no let me see you know and uh and it was
fine and since then it's
you know it's it's it's been fine and I
you know and it's it's and I
I don't know whether I've had any Eureka
moments of oh this is what it's all
about uh and any epiphanies but it's
it was a control thing I think and it
was also out of respect for my family
and you know my kids don't drink my boys
don't drink they don't you know which is
extraordinary yeah I was 12 hours
drinking yeah it is interesting that
generation doesn't have the same
relationship with alcohol that our
generation did like I've been out in
lots of you know kind of bars on the
east side with the boys playing gigs and
you know all these different venues
around L.A kind of the hip where like a
lot of 20-somethings are hanging out
and every time I look at Julian I'm like
nobody's drinking or maybe like you know
like maybe 10 to 15 percent of the
people have a beer in their hand that
they're nursing and that's just not what
it was like when we were that age oh man
you know being out right it was you know
I mean I'm sure there's a whole Litany
of other drugs that they're more
interested in but um but the the thing
with alcohol is very different yeah I
mean it was really cultural for us you
know as cultural is out there on films
and rock bands and you know it was just
par part of the course of growing up and
becoming a man you know like pants and
then we eat the whiskey you know and it
was that kind of thing and how you know
I think it's probably in my 40s is one
of my metabolism started to change you
drastically there was an element of
vanity as well that I thought you know I
I gotta keep in shape for my work and
also I want to clear a head so you stop
doing it but we we really we really were
born into a culture you know New York it
was rolling rocks as many as you can you
know down in an evening and it was all
that sort of stuff which what were your
bars in New York when you lived there oh
I was I mean I was chica's Locust was
the club that I used to go to in Tribeca
and Nells and bar Spring Spring Street
lounge do you remember that one on the
corner of uh Mulberry and spring that
was a great afternoon drinking but I
didn't I never went there oh that was
great it's all gentrified now it was a
really good time then in the 80s
um Nell's Lucky Strike Lucky Strike
Friday and Saturday I know it has hasn't
it I just saw that last year no that was
my my best mates who followed me to
America with DJs there so I was that was
my spot that was my spot I loved that
spot we had so much fun in that spot you
know
um but uh I mean it was just
I I think we've got to learn what our
limits are and how we want to create our
life right and so at some point you make
that decision I don't know whether I'll
you know I might drink again at some
point you know it was there was this
romantic idea I had that one day I could
introduce my boys to a glass of wine and
you know we could do that they're sort
of European they Europeans grow up
drinking and that's that but
you know I'm grateful that they're not
interested that they're not bothered
about it I think it's amazing I think
they realized a lot earlier
the value through Sports as well which
has been amazing for them but the value
of really taking care of yourself and I
think that's a positive of what they've
been exposed to
um having access to sort of YouTube
podcasts like yourself and well it's
it's really it's interesting and curious
and fascinating to me the idea of
somebody who isn't an alcoholic parting
ways with alcohol like because my you
know I'm I'm steeped in the world of you
know people whose lives have been
decimated as a result of drugs and
alcohol and the process of you know what
that breakup looks like and piecing your
life back together but but the idea of
somebody who really isn't a problem
Drinker like
breaking up with alcohol I think is
super interesting and is also a newer
kind of cultural phenomenon that didn't
quite exist like I had I don't know I
had a podcast with
this guy Andy rummage years ago he's a
British
former professional football player oh
yeah uh turned Banker traitor wow
who was living that lifestyle in London
where it's all about you know going out
after work it's Wall Street yeah exactly
yeah
um and had this Epiphany that it wasn't
working out for him and bucked the trend
of his industry and decided that he
wasn't going to drink anymore and
created this
um community and movement called one
year no beer and he wrote this book
about you maybe you've seen yeah no yeah
I guess it's a big thing in in the UK I
don't know but really oriented around
people who are not alcoholics but whose
lives can be improved by not drinking
anymore and all the benefits of that and
creating support for the non-problematic
drinkers to you know have a healthier
lifestyle and I think there's something
really cool about that I think that's
superb I haven't actually heard of that
but I'd love to look into that I think
uh I think for me it was out of respect
for my family and it was out of respect
of the situation this weird situation
that we're all collectively in you know
being on lockdown and it was controllers
I couldn't travel anymore I couldn't
work anymore I had to and your whole
like that's how you get your sustenance
yeah yeah that's that really is it you
know I go away I take I get my you know
I get my uh my fix of travel of
Adventure of of other people of uh
culture and then I come home and I try
and deliver and and you know employ that
in in being a good dad you know and
being a decent partner and and and I
think I just wanted to I think I was
it became
too habitual and I think if it's a
negative habit I think you have to
challenge that at some point because
otherwise you're going to be in the same
rut over and over and over again and I
just really wanted to
I wanted to I wanted to have a bit of
control over my life and I think that
gave me a goal you know to do it to to
have a good day and then I'll get
through a day and yeah I did okay and in
the morning I wasn't snoring I wasn't
you know I wasn't sort of feeling stinky
or whatever else and had a clearer head
in the morning and then was able to at
that point meditate and because there
was a bit more time and I wasn't that
was just before I started Mr feel good I
was just sort of figuring it out with
Pete where we were going designing the
ideas that we wanted to run with so I
love that idea though I must read that
book I love that idea and that was
really Brave of him that was really
Brave so actually I I would say from my
point of view to be in that environment
that sort of you know pack Brat Pack
whatever you want to call it yeah I
think that probably was the hardest part
for him because that was the culture of
his profession yeah completely that's
probably true for a lot of people
completely and also you know in the old
days the foot football profession as
well it was you know there was you know
half time and you you had a cup of tea
and a cigarette you know and then went
out and played another 45 minutes and
now of course everyone's got so much
information they're so conscious of
being at athletes and having to perform
uh you know at the top game bring always
bringing their top game that you you
have to look after yourself you know so
I think it's I think it's really
interesting how long have you been
married how many years you've been
married uh 1994 so what's that that's uh
28 coming up September the 3rd the day
World War II broke out yeah and our
eldest son's uh he was born two years to
the day on our wedding anniversary our
second wedding anniversary yeah so how
do you keep that fresh and healthy
um
I think going away helps I think having
your own
interests uh passions
um
helps I think just respect helps I think
I think you know holding hands holding
doors open I think
um really supporting your partners
talents and challenges and
um Ambitions you know and really
being respectful you know and sometimes
it's really challenging and sometimes
we've you know
is difficult obviously
um but I think it's just trying to
communicate
honestly and with respect and with
affection I think affection is really
important you know I think it's
I think it's
Carl you're making me a bit motion I
think it's really important to
to hold hands and to be
grateful and to
recognize because they go for changes as
we go through changes we're not the kids
we were when we're 20 in our 20s we're
sort of you know we're not
and you know all sorts of things happen
and um you've just got to
be open and present and and be be kind
you know and I I think I think you
should ask Allison this really yeah I
think I think
I'm fortunate because I've got someone
who's pretty steadfast
in who she is and and doesn't question
things that I questioned a lot more when
I was younger than I do now and it's
just so consistent and I think
she's taught me
especially in the last few years to
really be open and and
honest
about my own [__] you know I'm calling
me on my own [__] and um
and I think as I've wrestled with that
my egos wrestle with that but really
there's a part of me my nature is
harmony my nature is wanting to
not being conflict I I'm sort of
I'm willing to
you know be there and and and learn and
you know it's not a male and a female
kind of traditional you know archetype
it's a real we're a working team and we
are a working team and our kids see that
and you know they know what's come to me
for and they know what's come to their
mum for and she's an extraordinary
mother I mean she's extraordinary she's
an extraordinary mother she's an
extraordinary human but she's an
extraordinary mother
and I kind of
I see that and I see how that's matured
and developed over the years as we have
and it and it really is and it's just
you notice it and I just in awe of that
kind of
natural intuitive instinctual motherly
bond that she has with our kids and
there's been times when I've been you
know a little little Victory what about
me I'm your dad you know and stuff like
that but she's sort of
without really going into the Ethereal
and the spiritual signs of side of
aspects of life she's
she just kind of
she's okay you know she's she's secure
in that way she's so
she's exceptional but she's so regular
and consistent
yeah and it's just a really yeah that's
been a massive gift to me in my life and
I respect that and I honor that and you
know I think it's a case of
you know keeping the affection alive
keeping the the physical aspects of life
is really important to me uh that sort
of intimacy is really important to me
physically and
and mentally I think it's
I think it's honor I think it's just
honoring somebody trying to do the best
you can and sometimes I'm rubbish
um but I hope most of the time I'm I'm
you know my my intention is good and
honorable and and I think you just have
to even in The Madness of what we do in
our work and the world and everything
else I think you have to take time and
we you know tonight we're gonna have a
movie we're so excited to go and go to a
movie
um and and and you know and that's
really good we haven't been to a movie
together for about six months you know
because we've been too busy so it's fine
in that time and we go for a walk every
day but the kids come with us if they're
there and the dog you know and I think
that's a really nice thing to do just so
okay let's get out of the house let's
get away from this place and let's just
together
sort of just take the air and take a
nature
yeah all really basic things real basic
things yeah just you know and I think
and you do it over and over again and
also you know her parents are you know
18 8 and 89 her dad's 89 I mean they've
you know they've been in my life for a
long time and uh and she grew up in a
healthy she grew up so that's that
modeling yeah made her a healthy person
yeah it really pulls into your kids yeah
it does and they and they are very close
to their grandparents even though they
live in Yorkshire and our kids are over
here in California and New York
they and and my mum as well who's 88 and
is great but you know they they really
grew up with that what we lived here
Allison and I
um
we moved we were I was here for 12 years
between here in New York and Ali lived
with me in LA and then when Cooper was
born at nine months we moved back to
England because we wanted them to be
around their grandparents and I think
their grandparents were really sort of
involved with them and really made an
effort you know and every kid every
grandkid I think there's 11 of them all
together between Ali and her brothers it
always got
a card and always got the same amount of
money on the very consistent so she had
that they're so fair and you know every
day they do the telegraph crossword and
the Very
active in in sort of their respect for
each other the way they move around and
and Delight in each other still which is
because my papa no hair my father-in-law
is just I mean he's like he's he's gone
from being a lawyer all his life and a
golfer massive golfer and you know
presidents of uh several clubs and etc
etc very
traditional English solid background
who never they always say I taught him
how to hug
because because he's he in his
retirement and as he's gotten older he's
just literally become like a Buddha and
he's he's I mean a Buddha in a you know
in a very nice suit kind of thing or a
very nice shirt and tie impeccable but
he's just got this Joy about him and
this Freedom this Liberty and this
warmth now which is it's just infectious
and it's beautiful so I think having
Alison had that and my kids had that as
an influence in their life
um really sort of influenced the way we
go about it yeah in some ways it's
beautiful and it's positive and rare
yeah it's fantastic yeah
um one of the things this is kind of the
last thing I want to talk to you about
one of the things that I've been
spending a lot of time thinking about
and and also trying to improve in my
life is friendship especially at our age
like and for guys like back to kind of
mental health with men
um
I feel like women are are naturally
disposed to prioritize their friendships
in a way that that maybe guys aren't to
like make a blanket you know
stereotypical statement but I've just
noticed that I've allowed busyness and
also being a parent and other things
that are important to me to supplant uh
you know how I I practice friendship in
my life and I think living in Los
Angeles makes it difficult because
everything's so spread out if I was
living in London or New York or a place
like that where you know sort of moving
around and and being a social animal is
is is a more kind of fluid and
accessible experience than it is living
here so how have you you know thought
about or or you know maintained
friendships in your life like how do you
think about that I just I it's just
really vital to me I think it's so
important I've got a friend you know
I've got this friend who I've known
since I was eight years old came from
the same place as me his was the house
that his parents allowed me to go on
today and watch my first video I see my
first video machine you know and and
feel really safe there and
he's an extraordinary guy worked in
factories very working class he and his
wife adopted
a little boy they had a natural kid they
fostered kids they adopted this little
boy Brett and I think he was nine months
old and
Bret them was then diagnosed with uh
brain cancer for an 11 11 years they
took him all over the world and they
looked you know and they
total absolute contrasting life to my
life but he's one of the Dare the the
greatest parents I've ever known because
of what they've put into this day his
past four years now I think Brett's gone
they're still fostering kids and their
capacity
for for love and for openness and for
care of other people just blows me away
so he's a friend that I've remained in
touch I sent him a birthday card every
year since we're 12. and I always
remember and I and he didn't send me one
until I hit 50 and now he gets me before
I get him I think with friends I think
we I think if you've got a connection
I think you make an effort you know I
really care about the men in my life I
really care about them
um and I want to
sit them down and I want them to be able
to hang out and not feel they have to
talk I want them just to feel that
they're loved I want them to feel
they're respected I want them to feel
that they're
inspiring because they all are they've
all got character parts of their
character that's really important so I
think you do make an effort and we get
busy we're so busy and I'm already
thinking about two of my friends that I
want to talk to you know and I need to I
haven't spoken to them for a few days
but I always make an effort and I think
I think it's really important to do that
I think it's it's vital to us you know I
think it's you've got to have someone to
go and talk to and it's funny the ones
some of my friends I'm thinking of one
in particular
who has brought suffer very English you
know
um
just you know Eaton and Oxford and that
whole you know
sort of class
boarding school the whole nine yards and
there's a
kick ass mover and a Shaker who's
responsible for some of the
entertainment world's greatest greatest
most successful movies and when I sit
with him having known him 30 years and I
really want to see him because he's part
of the village that helps raise my kids
as I hope I do with his it's
extraordinary how
open hears how vulnerable how honest how
candid he is when we're together and I
think I provide that Avenue for him and
it's not a conscious thing it's just
something that's developed naturally
there's a trust there's a trust of
safety there's a trust you know and I
mean
and he's you know he I know he values
that and I value that and that's our
time so if it's a coffee or breakfast
together you know or it's a text you
know I tell him I love him all the time
I tell all my friends I love them
because I do
and I think that's really important to
you know there's nothing [__] about
that there's nothing effeminate or too
sensitive about that I mean
and if if people think there is I don't
care no I mean I could just share from
my own personal experience with you
you're so generous with your time and
your words like when I was in London and
I was staying at our mutual friends flat
and you know I would take a picture of a
of a I would see a like a hockney and I
know David hockney here in London and
then you would send me five paragraphs
on like all the places I should go and
what's Magnificent about London and make
sure you go here and with such a like a
generosity of spirit and you know that I
think is rare and and beautiful oh man I
I bless you I I just I I I I hope it's
not rare no I hope it is rare well if it
is rare then we've got to then then it's
about us just pushing it a bit and
making sure our friends are okay and
make I do that because I'm so grateful
to you for what you do and it just
you're in my town and I just want you to
see the best you know I'm a brilliant
tourist guide in New York LA and and
London and and and and I love it I I
thrive on being able to show people a
different side of things and so those
things I sent you is just knowing who
you were
who you are having read your book and
having gotten to know you over the
couple of last couple of years it was
just natural for me to want to share
that because whether you do it or not
you've got it now and next time you're
there I want you to take me by I only
did like maybe one of them that's okay
she told me two things two things you've
got to do is one you've got to take a
bike ride around Richmond Park you've
got to sneak through the gate under a
full moon you've got to do that that'll
just be so good for you I think and the
other thing is you've got to swim in the
sort of the baths in Hampshire you know
that was the one thing I I thought I was
gonna make time for on it well you will
do make it happen you will do all right
um I think um I think it's I think
I think you know I think in a way when
you go to all the support you've had
through your life with your challenges
didn't don't you feel a connection and a
friendship and a and a transaction in
the most positive way with the people
that you stand with in meetings or oh
for sure you do yeah of course but do
you just sort of leave that and and
that's
you know you can't compartmentalize that
or do you I'm presuming you work with as
a mentor for people not in any kind of
formal way right I mean there's people
in recovery and that's a separate thing
um but just in terms of like I wouldn't
say I'm formally anybody's Mentor but I
try to be generous with my time yeah my
you know maybe not advice but you know
experience based whatever I can share
that can be helpful to other people so I
do put I put time and energy into that
and that those are like daily text
messages yeah lots of different people
for the most part but like for
occasional phone calls yeah but for
instance when you when I reached out to
you and said should we have a chat sure
ever catch up you come back from England
I've been in Europe as well it was just
you know I didn't know
if you had time because I presume like
me you know you're you're very busy
um and I also respect that you need your
time out and you want to go cycling I
presume and that you want to have that
time to just sort of you've got a lot
going on so I respect the fact that
you're a very busy man but we met right
and I had no idea that this would be the
the fruit of what we sat down I just
wanted to see you because I really
wanted to see you you know and it to me
it was those sort of things whether
they're spontaneous and usually when
it's spontaneous I find it's even better
and it's more inspiring
um just a
that's the magic of friendship you know
sitting down and having a conversation
like we're doing now and just being able
to
learn something be challenged you know
um feel warm feel safe you know and and
know that the person's opposite you and
you do this so well really has
your best intentions at heart you know
and that's a that's a beautiful thing
man that's got such power
to support and Inspire and and and as an
example as well to my kids you know when
I go and see my friends and I come back
with an idea or some kindness
in an interchange or something that I
hadn't recognized either good or bad I
taught very frankly with my my family
and my kids my my boys especially my
daughters in L.A sorry in New York and
and that just cements the
my reason and my desire to actually keep
doing this because it feels good I'm
sorry I'm not I'm really not me I'm not
I'm not it's not a commercial but it
really it really does right that's
coming out a lot more actually which is
really funny just in my day-to-day and
it's not conscious but it's interesting
how this thing that was there and now it
I'm 100 in it and it's literally
manifesting from me and that's a that in
a way is uh
it's it's a lovely way of sustaining
oneself even though I don't consciously
choose to do that but it is it is a case
of I think
you know it's if if you feel good if you
vibrate at a certain level if you can
push yourself when you don't I mean I
thought about it coming here and I
actually mentioned it to my boys you
know I say don't say this don't say that
and I'm like I don't want to say
anything I just want to be free and I
want to be open to you because you
deserve that because of the work you do
and and I said I kind of feel like
Rich because I was never a long distance
Runner I was a Sprint I was a very good
Sprinter and um and and when I've tried
it I think I've done once I did a 5K and
that was it and it took me you know
three and a half hours and uh whatever
and I think that it was an interesting
idea I thought okay I'm feeling a bit
nervous of what because I want to give
you everything and I wanna all the
different things you you know doubts or
whatever you have when you're coming
into a situation and but I wanted to be
mostly I wanted to be honest and I want
to be present for you and I thought I
wonder this feeling I'm not gonna I'm
gonna go with it I'm gonna go with it
because I trust that it's going to be
beautiful and I trust that there's going
to be some some something real and uh
come out of it but I did think about you
when you're running and when you're on
the 22nd mile or whatever it is and it's
really [__] hard work to push
yourself off from my perspective to put
even at 5K to push that foot in front of
the other and this is what I got from
your book as well and just to keep going
keep going get to the other side and I
thought well it's almost the same
mentally if you can
you know utilize that skill and that
mindset to just push you a little bit
further mentally or in public speaking
or whatever it is
then that's that's what you got to do
you got to chip away at that mountain
get that higher and get a bit higher and
just it really is a case of Will and a
case of applying yourself and and you
know
not giving in to those little you know
doubts or traitors that make us lose
what we oft might win by failing to
attempt I think Shakespeare said
something like that you know you've just
got to keep
cracking on so I think I just took us on
a whole tangent didn't yeah sorry I know
it is it is true and you know the the
magic is in the chipping right yeah you
want to think about the the grand
gestures and the you know the the sort
of sweeping success yeah Etc but it's
really the the you know unromantic and
unglorious yeah little chipping away
every single day when no one's looking
yeah it is and like any anything
worthwhile demands that and you're in it
right now yeah man I mean what did you
call it I think a couple of years ago
you're in the fire yeah I think you're
in the fire I think you said Julie had
said something like that and I was like
oh please let me be on the fire this and
I knew it was just the beginning then
when I interview you so I thought oh my
goodness so I really relate to your
story I really really it's different uh
different different
colors and paints but it's the same sort
of basic thing you know we're we're
grafting and it's and and and you know
we've got to get through we've got to
keep going and there's someday days
where I'm overwhelmed and I feel like I
just want to you know hide away or get
on a motorbike and just get out into the
desert and sort of lose myself or drink
and I think now he's just gotta you
gotta let it go you gotta keep going and
and then it sort of takes on its own
momentum and you and you think actually
I actually made it I made deadline last
night okay I managed to put all these
things together and look how good it
looks and look how well it's written not
me I'm not saying just me but it's
there's an honesty and an Integrity
there and so that you know that gives me
a little more confidence and then I'll
but I keep at it I keep at everything
I'm I'm definitely apart from long
distance running maybe one day you'll
take me I'm terrified but uh you know
maybe until my lungs are like you know
let me get my back bursting I know are
you okay no yeah yeah
um but also you are a friend and and you
are someone you're gonna have to take
this for a second you're someone I
admire tremendously and inspired by you
tremendously and the fact that you give
me time as well like we did it when we
met for a cup or a juice
you know that's just brilliant that
means so much to me and it inspires me
and then I you know it's a ripple effect
and that's I just think if we brought
more kindness
and um
presence and and
sustained
um support
into the circle of people that we
interact with whether it's your audience
or whether it's your family and friends
I think that's a really positive move
forward
well I appreciate that and I'm certainly
all about that and to the extent that I
can you know be
um available to you to help you in that
regard and I love that idea that you
mentioned earlier about the round table
Yeah I think there's something really
special about that so there really is
and I've already got a there's a there's
a list in my head it was interesting it
I was shooting and writing to about
Nikolai Nicolo sorry Nicolo beanie uh
the architect The Architects and and
he's an extraordinary man and he's full
of passion and life and
an affection he's Italian but he grew up
in Australia and then came to California
and you know he's got the best of all
those cultures and really warm human
being and we went to shoot him uh take
photographs of him uh his house
and uh I'd interviewed him in January
but you know if we we had to hold off
for one reason or another and uh at the
end of it there was just myself and the
photographer in his home and he'd done
this lovely plate of Italian foods you
know cheeses and hams etc etc and we sat
down and the conversation we had
afterwards was just so incredible and so
beautiful and
Alex the photographer who's probably 30
or 32.
um who really wanted to shoot Nick
because he just he'd met him once before
and loved him in his energy we sat down
and we had this conversation the next
day I said I said wasn't that wonderful
what didn't it feel good and he was like
oh absolutely I said and the pictures
are amazing you know we did it like in
an hour and really good pictures you
know really great we really captured his
soul and he said yeah it really was
amazing he said but what was most
amazing was the conversation we had
afterwards and that was a kid who's 30.
and it just made me think that I know
like 10 men that I know that I've such
you know respect for and I just thought
we should sit down and we should all
talk about this we should film it we
should we should make it natural and
real but useful to other kids and to
other people as an example of what can
be done in a in a masculine way in a you
know we're not you know in a really
elegant true real way have a
conversation we all need to you know
Listen and talk more of course right
that's why we're both doing what we're
doing yeah we are and I bless you well
bless you uh to be continued to be
continued the conversation is just one
conversation yeah right on
um
you're more beautiful on the inside than
the outside uh I I do consider you a
friend and I appreciate the energy that
you brought to this today and please
consider me you know at your service for
anything that you need in in service to
what you're trying to express and
manifest because I think it's really
cool and special so thanks John
bless you man bless you I really
appreciate you thank you all right cool
thank you
[Music]
foreign